hello there today I thought we could use
slow-mo to learn how the Nintendo zapper
worked this was a peripheral for the
original Nintendo the NES used with
games such as duck hunt from
1984 and this is an incredibly clever
piece of Kit especially for its time a
little bit before my time I grew up with
this bad boy probably the best little
gray box ever made although I was quite
surprised when I moved to America that
their version of the Super Nintendo
looked like that
which I think is deeply unfortunate okay
now that I'm done annoying half the
audience let's get on with it the
Nintendo zapper I think the original one
was gray this was a a later version in
Orange and in games such as duck hunt it
could tell exactly where you had this
pointed without using any other piece of
equipment other than the gun itself
please forgive the line that's moving
down the screen right now I can't see
that with my eyes but uh we'll learn why
that happens in the slow-mo have you
spotted how this works you can see it
with your eyes but the slow-mo will
really help us out you'll notice that
every time I pull the trigger a white
box will appear around the
duck and the white box is what this is
looking for here we are at 10,000 frames
a second as we learned in previous
videos each frame is drawn by the TV
from top to bottom line by line and if
we slow the footage down to 82,000
frames a second you can see that each
line shoots AC Ross the screen from left
to right extremely quickly here's the
same action slowed down to 1.75 million
frames a second at this speed a second
lasts almost 19 hours a little bit of
maths tells us that this specific screen
is capable of drawing a line from the
left to the right of the frame at
approximately
24,500 mph that effectively means that
given an hour a line moving at this
speed could travel around the entire
circumference of the earth you can see
here that at no point on a CRT display
do you see an entire frame at once when
filming at the speed you can only see
the current line being drawn and it's
actually your eyes Persistence of vision
that lets you see an entire frame at
once so I'm going to artificially extend
the trails of each frame to make it
easier for us to see which frame is
being drawn in this game it seems as
though every new frame has the duck in a
different position on the screen it
doesn't necessarily change the Animation
Sprite but the duck model is drawn in a
slightly different spot every time so
now I'm going to turn off the trails and
go back to the actual Raw footage of how
these scan lines look when the trigger
is pressed the zapper sends a signal
down to the console and this light
sensor at the back of the gun is now
looking at a focused area of the screen
through this lens take note of where the
duck is here the console will then
finish drawing its current frame and
then send an entirely black frame to the
display nothing is drawn and on the next
frame a white box is drawn exactly over
where the Sprite of the duck was whether
or not the zapper saw that white box
determines what happens next in this
instance I got a successful hit on the
duck so the game redraws the background
with no Sprites on it drew it again but
with only the score updated and then the
next frame we see the flying duck Sprite
replaced with the shot duck and the game
continues all in all here the duck was
gone for four frames but it's so fast
that you barely notice with your eyes
and you'll see that when I play in two
duck
mode there'll be two white boxes to aim
at I was quite surprised to learn that
in two duck mode it actually draws each
box on a different frame that was frame
one it's now going all the way to the
bottom starting again at the top and
drawing a white box for the second duck
it then takes multiple passes to draw
each Sprite back in and you can see
there I shot at the second duck one of
the reasons it draws an entirely black
frame before any of the white boxes is
so you can't just point the gun into a
bright light source like a light bulb it
actually has to see black then white a
frame later otherwise it won't reward
any points I then opened up the aperture
fully on my lens to let in even more
light and noticed that there is even a
faint line when it draws an entirely
black frame a vector display would only
draw the lit areas and move about the
screen almost willy-nilly but because
this is rasterized frames the beam will
travel over every area of the screen
whether it draws anything or not so the
zapper itself isn't actually shooting
anything the TV isn't receiving anything
this is the receiver and it's just using
its little lens here to search for the
white on the screen they also thought
about menu navigation with the zapper
you can navigate and select everything
on the menu with just this one button
and uh it uses the exact same method it
flashes the entire screen on the menu
and when it detects no flash the
selected menu item changes and then when
it detects the flash it selects it so
instead of the tiny little square it'll
Flash the whole screen and use the exact
same method on the menu and that is a
lot of dead Ducks I honestly think this
is such a Genus piece of engineering the
fact that one peripheral and one cable
was then compatible with pretty much
every TV in existence at the time 40
years ago just blows my mind a little
bit I just think it's so cool let me
know in the comments of any other
electronics that worked in really
interesting ways that would be cool to
film in slow-mo I'm very interested to
learn about all that stuff hopefully you
enjoyed this short little video make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
and what what were they doing with this
like what was
the